Steve Tasker made a living as a Pro Bowl
special teamer he worked with CBS as one
of their analyst and kind enough to join
us on short notice
Steve thanks for joining us what do you
think now how long is it a matter of if
not if but when we get ready to kick off
yeah I think so and I think I don't know
if it'll be gotten rid of I guess the
way it stands now it probably will be
but I think the fun part about it is and
I know people are like it's really
difficult to say goodbye to something
that's part of the vernacular I mean but
I think people are going to find that
the league is really going to do their
best to replace it is something that's
even better I think that's the real
challenge the thing is one of the things
that's made the NFL great and made it
the 800-pound gorilla in five sports in
America is the fact that it changes all
the time
they tinker with it to give fans more of
what they want and less of what they
don't like so I think they'll come up
with something after a field goal or a
touchdown extra point to transition the
ball back to the other team in some
creative way that's not quite so violent
as a kickoff and if they can figure out
a way to do that I think they're
perfectly ready to give it a try how
unsafe is the kickoff it's it's by
statistically speaking more injuries
happen on it than any other and you know
you're talking like for every kick for
every hundred kickoff returns maybe
you'll get three injuries and maybe a
third of those injuries will be
concussions or maybe a little bit more
than that maybe half of them of these
concussions because you got guys running
full-speed down the field and other guys
that are not running quite full speed
yet turning around to take those guys on
and nobody's trying to avoid the contact
yeah they're all trying to take each
other on at full speed and that's the
answer recipe for disaster and and
that's what they've been tinkering with
with all the ways since 1974 they've
been tinkering with where they kicked
the ball off probably used to be the 40
yard line and then his kickers got
better and better they moved it back to
get more returns you know because back
then nobody really you know knew
anything about player safety it was it
was a different world back then so
they've they've it's evolved much over
the last 20 years at least
but what about
the violence on touchbacks because I
tell people you're just watching the
football you're not watching the
collisions upfront where this might be
the only play you're in in the game or
you might be on the field for four plays
and their kickoffs you want to get your
money's worth if you're out there
playing don't you that's right I mean
yeah you know you're not gonna go half
speed just because you don't think
they'll run it out of the end zone and
you know that's the way it's like I said
I mean these guys are out there to
compete at the highest level they don't
care if it's for money or marbles or
chalk they're gonna win every play they
can and that's you know there's no
escaping and that's why I think it's you
know the evolution is going to continue
downward till it's it's drastically
different than it has been how unsafe is
the punt return
well the punt return is kind of the same
same situation although it's a little
safer punt return team is one of those
it's the same thing yet guys run in a
lot of open space they get caught off
guard because they're either looking up
and trying to find the ball or looking
around trying to find the returner and
they get lit up and that's the kind of
thing that is second only to kickoff
return as this part return is being you
know the most unsafe and where you get a
lot of injuries and while the
differences you know statistically is
kind of miniscule it there is a
significant difference between those and
regular down a distance place so I don't
know that they'll do too much with punt
punt return because there is a
significant difference in that's those
stats and injuries but they they're
looking at everything now and trying to
give or come up with creative and more
fun alternatives would you have had a
career if there weren't kick homes
probably not probably not but then again
damn they don't owe me a job I mean I
evolved
I had great coaches who found a role for
me and I tried to make myself valuable
but it's not like they're cutting the
teams if you don't who kicked off you're
gonna cut five guys off the roster
there's still gonna be five jobs there
for guys who wouldn't have had a job had
to kick off stayed around so you get
that sort of cuts both ways now they
start talking about making the rosters
35 instead of 45
then I'd have a problem with it but
they're not taking jobs away they're
just changing roles I don't have a real
problem with that I when I work with
Rodney Harrison and of course he was a
violent player he would he watches now
and he says I don't know how I played
that game and I'm curious you're down on
the sidelines for all of these games and
I tell these guys they get the guys I
work they get tired of hearing this if
you heard the game on the sidelines you
didn't have to watch it just hear it
you'd never let your kid play football
it's so it's so vile it's so different
down there Steve yeah you're right I
mean I tell people if you've ever if you
ever get a chance to watch the game on
the sidelines don't do it you'll never
watch first you'll never want to watch
it anyplace else and secondly you see
the size and the speed of these guys
it'll turn their insides to water I mean
it it is a different game but by the
same token I'm I'm a big proponent of
youth football I think it's a great idea
no question there is a physical risk but
I have four sons they all played and
they all got great benefit out of it and
I think that's one of the things that I
say to moms who ask me I say let your
kids play when they're little and make
them quit when they're 15 because once
they cross the bridge of adulthood and
turn and go past puberty then they start
to play angry but up until then there's
so many positive benefits from the use
for that particularly football that I
think because of the risk is there I
think the benefit is ten times more than
the risk there is to injury I I'm a big
proponent of the game specifically for
youth but when they get older and
heavier and faster and stronger that's
when it becomes the game you and I watch
on the sidelines and it's not for the
faint of heart
Steve thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time then I appreciate
it good talking to you Steve Tasker CBS
sports seven-time Pro Bowl special
teamer probably wouldn't had a career at
least at the Pro Bowl level without the
kickoff for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]